I'm please they grew up in here
and i don't know i am i'm
just sort of places that i mean i wouldn't
among them grow up anywhere else.
Probably because this is my
home. I've been never home.
And we had no trouble with them.
Well one of the real the real things i
would have been exposed to was drugs
but not at that festival time like that
was later sort of in the years to come
but i must say that up until i
actually left time and then came back
that they were never offered drugs and
they were you know it was up there
but the truth.
All lies years of being young students
here they were never ever offered drugs by
anybody but they were out there
and i knew they were out there
and i think just.
Well even long live was a lot of drainage
people so that sort of taught them
that they had to be very careful of who
they talk to or who they got to know.
So that sort of made them for that much
better in their lives that they knew
that you know you didn't
trust any everybody.
But then again like i said
we were lucky we had them.
You know people would come here to
the house and that sort of things
that they sort of grew up with
a. I've started of the fence.
You know we went we
went to paradise valley
and had dinner with friends out there
that we got to know we had people come here
off the communes to have meals with us.
We've been to tangible
and took the children with just so you
know that's why i think they got to know
that there wasn't the most and
just a straight line in life
that there was two sides to it and
and both sides could be quite
pleasant if you look at it.
The two girls and the two older
girls live in this in lismore.
But they were married and
they went in there to live
and they've all got the
four lost two husbands
and the two wives got
jobs in this analyst.
They're quite happy to live in jail
and i'll be home on thursday because
she's at college and i am a da
and that was her choice
that she you know and
that she wanted to have a brighter
life from neiman she was probably the
one that was born.
And she doesn't know the other side
of nimbin because she was born like
that in the or with them.
That people arrived in so she only knows a
lot of nimbin as it is now not as it was
before and that was
probably the other thing
that was a fear for me was before
the festival your kids could go
and be away an hour and you knew that
they were either talking to an aunt
or an up or an old friend where
if they were gone for 10 minutes.
You were concerned as you know that you
know where are they. Who's got them.
And that because
that was a fear for me personally having
three young children where before that
that was probably a different
a change in nimbin for me
that before the festival of my children
could be gone for an hour up this.
Right after that if they
were gone for five minutes.
I would be going to see where they
were so that changed my life in
that respect
that i had to be more aware where my
children were than i was before i
was young people on drugs.
It would have to be my.
I said it's moments in the
nt and i think i've got it.
I've got a lot of fond memories
of the festival and after but
that would have to be i
think the saddest thing
that i do see is young people been
blown away by drugs and it would.
If i could round them all up
and say come on we're going
to get right away from this.
It wouldn't have to be the
thing that i would change in
that change.
Yes that. It.
It wasn't here with the festival
and i wouldn't say that.
Not the heavy stuff.
But after the first one i think we found
a little pot of marijuana growing it rip
around like which people were
probably having a smoke around.
That's their business and
that is their concern.
But i think then it came to dealing.
But i think that's probably only
happened sort of say in 10 years.
The last 10 years where we've got
the dealer coming into town and
that sort of thing where i mean
it's the same as anything else
that if you've just got it.
People want to have a cigarette.
Marijuana whatever they call
it that is their business.
But i do i think the line
should be drawn somewhere
that people are selling it to
other people's children that
that is as a very big
concern of mine you know
and like i said i don't know what i would
have done had i had of sort of had them
offering it to mine but i can say
that it never happened until now it's
happening that they've gone away
and they're coming back and they are sort
of rising up to them now on the street
and saying they want to buy it but up
until then it was never offered to them
but that would be my saddest thing about
an in-born is that it is out there
and i so young lives been destroyed by it.
Not you know i couldn't say i have.
But i think if you live here
and in such a small community yes it touches
you personally just to see any one's
child. You can stand back and say well
i don't care because you do care.
And.
I just said you know it is it's really an
truly stand to see if some of those kids
up there are so young
and i think if we you know just
like to see the deals be taken away
and i'm sure we'd be that that
is our problem now we've got it
and i don't know i don't
know how to fix it
and i think that's the most
aggravating part of it
that you don't know i
had it fix it yourself
and you don't know if anyone else
can fix it either. You know.
A half as you know i think i think it's it
is it will be we just don't know how to
deal with it any of it you know we can
talk about it and say well. And i suppose.
We can all sort of try and
blame other people for it
but that's not fixing it is that you know
and we don't mean it were and i think
that is why we do try and pass the
blame on this one or that one
or someone else inside.
If we didn't have a festival it wouldn't
have happened if we didn't do this or
that what wouldn't have happened but it
is happening. And that's not the point.
We've got and we were just south helpless
we don't know what to do about it
and maybe will never be able to fix it.
I don't know but it is a concern
that would have to be my biggest
that every my saddest thing
about living in the main thing
is you know i just think living in
is like i've had my life has been good
and it's because i live here.
I've got a good husband.
I had read three beautiful
children and i've had a good job.
I work with good people and you know i
thought oh my life in general has been good.
Like i said and i think
and i don't think i could have been
happier if i'd lived anywhere or so
and it was very what is.
This.
You know not really you know i
just think it's nimbin nimbin
and i don't think i could say well.
How to describe it it's just it's
got a there's a drawcard to it.
But like i said if you haven't
got a sense of humor you
that live here you've got to be
prepared to be able to laugh at things.
If you take life seriously nimbin
is not for you not like your people
that they come and say oh
you've lived here it is.
Think i guess i got a
sense for him forget it.
I know i know i really haven't i
don't i haven't got a funny story
and i think i've got really you
know i have to think about it but
that be lots of funny things that happened
in my life that you could laugh about.
I think the mind i think
there's probably well
probably during the first of when i didn't
run down the street but no flies on
and i have a bobbing along you know and
i far as you know after about that
but nothing really.
It's like the funny things. It's happened.
I like anything in particular
that i could sort of say well yes
that was probably when you've gone off my
heart you know telling that story but.
You know you know i'm thank you.
I'm sally sara and i was
very very busy jr..
During the first festival i
mean i was nimble to go home
and i had such a full
time job of making the
streets presentable and
clean enough for everyone
and the toilet job was a quite a handful
and i have a bit of other.
Counsel judy. Yes to do.
Beside that but mainly. My only
my full days were taken up with.
Just looking after the street and particularly
the garbage there was so much of it.
What do you. Like.
People.
My memories back of the first of all
i. On that's quite such a shame.
Quite a few nice new people that came and.
Quite a few of them are still here.
And the way i feel.
Most of those who want to leave
here and do the right thing there.
They're not really happy with.
Having another festival so nice.
Here i think they might feel.
And that's quite a lot goes
on that shouldn't be going on
and may not may not feel happy about it.
Do you think so.
My farewell to
you for that. Well if i
know as much of a home now.
I certainly would have been
very much other guys because.
Oh so many things went on.
Particularly the way people
walk from quite a distance.
People quite a distance walking
from where they lived and camped.
To shower rooms and
that i mean it didn't matter who
you know what you were they had.
They walk completely uncovered and.
At least i feel i could have been a towel.
And some of the other places that were.
Some of the tents and things
that you got to walk past well.
When mum and dad. Was.
Leading the way of course
they they probably stopped
and turned the children
back the other way.
So they wouldn't see what
was going on. In the team.
So yeah they changed their action.
And. There was so much
happening that happened then.
In the drug needling part where
they were so many. So many use needles.
Even lying about.
And working they don't ever seems well.
It was no it was no problem at
all for me the trying to claim.
In that clean the dump and
we cycle it and come across.
I don't mind needles in one place without
any trouble and move on a bit further
and come across more still
with a needle in them.
So it would have been very risky to.
To even put your hands or feet
anywhere near the needles
or what you didn't know was already there.
That was on the first of all
time but it's. It's been there.
It has been the same until just recently
when the dump us has changed
hands a bit for recycling
people but.
The need to have a very right
up until just recently and.
As i go in our times for a better
recycling even at the showground well
there's plenty of needles left
just anywhere at the showground
and i'd be.
I'd be very much against a
festival restarting like it was
then. Because.
It's risky even walking about now and.
What will be like weather
with a bigger crowd
and the drugs don't ever seem to.
Don't seem to slacken off any
day and to be just as many.
Much now as it ever was.
Was.
I just don't know of
anything really that they.
What real good the first of all did
you know name when it was so small
and probably going back but.
It has brought business and
that into town.
But when so many. Very rough
and layabout people
you've got a job even to walk in the
street because there are so many.
They're sitting around your layout around
and they don't even make
room for oldies who was
clear particularly for
the australian rural
or shopping shopping trolley.
Or kiddie stroller and that there's
barely room to get past them.
I can't i can't say it's done a really
lot of good a lot of good for no.
I did find there was some.
Some very good musicians
among the the new settlers
and very very talented in music
and.
Sometimes i quite often join them
and i do a lot of singing.
I still do it. It's 70 you know 79
and sometime the all time it turn
people into like me they come along
and sing while they do the backing
and i i really enjoy it.
I just can't think of any.
Special time i had with them occasionally
though not so long.
Back occasionally they were
performed on the nimbin showground
and i joined in with them
and done quite a few items
with there and holger.
No whole public in general
really enjoyed it. That's.
A couple of. Special times
i can remember with them.
Some of the songs that i there with
the people if they don't know them.
If they don't know them themselves.
Like i have music and they
can follow them that way.
Some of them are quite up to date.
Country and western songs
such as one day at a time
and please help me i'm falling
and the good old days here day and.
Also pearly shells
and i
usually say you come with a name and lives
and they tell them without
there's only one my wife
and on very happy that.
If i sound like him but
i'm not going to try
and either last has really only one girl.
Also i can do the.
I have a good allies song for
the oldies all in general.
Have been guys these go away by.
Produce that one sometimes.
And if anyone wants gospel songs will
they come to the right place because i
i can certainly certainly
handle the gospel and.
I'm doing it regularly the moment
memory all the local churches
went to sydney recently to groom
sounds were nearly the man i was
saying especially one who
is wearing which i did
and i just come back from a lovely
weekend then in tenterfield i
sang in two two churches
a tenterfield plus.
Three other three other out into
the senior citizens which gave me
five things songs in three days so
i think about coming home from all
that i.
Time jobs.
Yes.
Yes i and i was in 1973 i was in. Oh.
I'm don johnston and back in 1973
when equities vegetable was murdered.
I was a dairy farmer here at
bishop's creek which is near nim.
When and i would also
and a counsellor on the main issue i counsel
which i later become amalgamated with
little more city council. We did
make a decision back in seventy two.
Just before the chris festival to allow
the festival to be held in nimbin.
And.
That's about as far as i'm concerned
the situation would have possibly been
that there were only three
or four did object to the.
At the public meeting
that they shouldn't have their queers
festival the rest of nimbin seem to be going
along with it.
So that's where the high council made the
decision to allow it to be held and.
Looking back in those days i feel it
only one thing that we should have done
and that was probably to
put a bigger bond on the.
Festival committee because they clean our
program later left a lot to be desired
and the mania shire council
had a pick up the tab for it.
Yes i was around for all of the festival.
I was also president of
the nimbin bowling club
and the festival was right beside it
and my wife was heavily committed to a
church organization by having meals like
soups and and teas
and running other for the people
who were visiting the festival
and so i was committed every day
and every night at the club
and help helping organizations
and even taking in the some of
the visitors to their camps
and wanting other during the night.
It was different. It was
most certainly different.
I feel that the young people
most of the young people
that were there didn't really understand
what they were there for that was my.
First impression of a lot of the people
but they certainly enjoyed themselves
for those 10 days that they were there
and most certainly they were helped
by everyone in yemen to try to join
in and be part of it.
Oh some of the funny sites
were probably the first time
that we've seen a lot of people
getting around with no clothes on.
Even in fairly.
Populated streets and one thing another. I
don't think too many talk a great deal.
Another top it but i do believe that
some of the things and one of the things
that have come from what i believe was
the presence of drugs and i do know
that the local constabulary they
told them told the committee
that they would not be hard on them if they
only used soft drugs such as marijuana
but once they used hard drugs they
would clampdown on them which they did
and i can remember one distinct episode
where a group of people could be number
twelve or fifteen hundred got bolt cutters
and cut the handcuffs off a prisoner
that a detective had.
Not really though very little of fighting
between themselves or with anyone else.
It was a really good time with
lots of really good music
and lots of good time for
most of the people concerned
or there were the only those isolated
actions that i believe that did married
but not to any great extent.
Well the good thing they left.
I believe there are some very talented
people in the area and they probably.
Them from their aquarius
festival or have got.
Media coverage since a lot of
people with great talents and arts
and crafts we have some very good craft
shops and workshops in the village now
that can be put down as
from the aquarius festival.
There's also probably a lot of money
being generated by people there whether
or not it's because of dole or because
of invalid pensions or whatever
but there is a lot more money
in newbern at the present stage
and they were back in not before 1973.
You know ne'eman a lot of people say
it was a becoming a ghost town.
I don't believe
that for one moment it was going through
what we'd call a probably a recession.
It was just coming to the stage where
we had some about a total of about 100
dairy farms in the area.
We had around but a factory
that all fell by the wayside it
was just trying to deteriorate.
We had about four or five miles in the
area one mile in a time had 28 employees.
And now we're back to one meal so yes
there has been a decline in industry
and i think that's the big problem we've
got in nimbin at the present stage not
enough in industry and it.